[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to have him with us for the year and
have him with us for the evening and so
with that i'll turn it over to you eric
thank you scott um it's really great to
be here um
my name's eric gordon as scott just said
and
i've been yeah i've been i'm here for
this year
at mit and um and really enjoying my
time so far so getting it speak in this
forum is really
just a just an honor so
let me share my screen and hopefully
this will go well hold on one second
no do you see a you see a
towards a meaningfully inefficient smart
city slide so you see
yep okay good and let me try this
all right wonderful so um
yeah so my talk tonight is uh is
entitled towards a meaningfully
inefficient smart city i will explain
all those words
uh in in a bit uh so please be patient
with me as i do that um
as scott mentioned uh i direct the
engagement lab
uh at uh at emerson and and we
have focus in the intersection of of uh
of play and civic life for for some time
and
um and the work that i'm going to talk
about tonight is both
emerging out of uh out of the work that
i've been doing for
for nearly a decade now um but but also
um firmly tied to a recent book um that
i
i published in in march which i'll talk
a little bit about
so let me start by telling you what you
already know that on may 25th
george floyd was murdered by minneapolis
police officers
the next day a video of the crime was
circulated on social media and the city
erupted in protests soon after
and within a week throngs of people
demanding racial justice
took to city streets all over the
country and the world
soon after a majority of minneapolis
city councillors pledged to defund the
city's police department
and they said we are here today this is
their pledge we are here today to begin
the process of ending
the minneapolis police department and
creating a new transformative model for
cultivating
safety in minneapolis
and since this time it has largely
fallen apart
there's such a sense of urgency around
trying to start some sort of
community engagement process that is
staff led and better embedded in the
city enterprise says uh counselor bender
um so that it isn't just the policy
makers having these separate
conversations and our awards that aren't
recorded or captured anywhere
so that we can help to build confidence
in our community that we are moving
forward in a way that reflects the
complexity
of the multiple layers of crisis
one resident of north minneapolis a
predominantly black and brown
neighborhood had this to say about the
effort
they didn't engage black and brown
people referring to the city council
members and
something about that does not sit right
with me something about saying to the
community we need to make change
together
but instead you leave this community and
me unsafe
so the decision was given over to
minneapolis charter to a minneapolis
charter commission a mostly white
appointed commission that decides
matters of changes in the city's charter
and then last week just last week the
commission has put the ballot initiative
on pause
and the city's relationship with the
police department is about where it was
in may so this story is a complex
morality tale
it's a story about the success of the
movement for black lives
the mainstreaming of racial justice as a
legitimate and essential concern for
elected officials
it's also a story about the failure of
procedures of governance
to fill to facilitate changes in policy
the failure of institutions to adapt to
sentiment
my talk today is about institutioning
the process by which interventions big
social movements or small programmatic
designs
transform the institutions that enable
them and while especially
in the media disciplines we tend to
focus on large social movements and
specific
media interventions the process of
institutioning
is often where lasting transformation is
located
so hoibrecht said all argue that the
engagement with procedures of
institutions is necessary
to re-politicize participatory and
co-design practices
the missing link for progress is the
transition from movement politics or
specific interventions
to sustainable institutional
transformation
the example of minneapolis is not unique
over the last several months u.s cities
have challenged their ability to govern
with their stated values and because of
widespread social movements these values
are often newly discovered by
policymakers they are they feel newly
discovered by policymakers it's one
thing for elected officials to call foul
and make a decree it is quite another to
generate and enable the trust
and social capacity necessary for
systemic change
so this is the focus of my research and
i'm lucky enough to have it also be the
focus of my teaching this semester
the co-design studio i'm teaching is
focused on designing the mechanisms for
communities to effectively co-create
with city government and boston
uh we have counselors andrea campbell
and and julia mejia are partners in the
course
and both have expressed similar
sentiments
the city council in boston is more
represented
but representative of the city
population than it ever has been
it's majority women and nearly half
people of color
but the mechanics of governance have
largely stayed the same
so our studio class has 11 community
partners
and it brings together students with
city staff and community leaders to
co-design mechanisms of collaborative
governance in boston
so why am i speaking about this in a
media department and not a policy
department
because local governments governance is
mediated
by digital and analog communication
from voting to town hall meetings to
information dissemination and advocacy
and because media studies scholars
especially folks like me with a
background in the humanities have a
great deal to say about the interface
between expression
technology and power and the processes
by which it is integrated
into into institutional logics
at a time when trust in government is at
an all-time low
where nationalist and populist leaders
are trafficking and misinformation
campaigns
and diminishing trust in institutions is
a feature
not a bug it is difficult to have much
faith in government
i acknowledge and share that concern
but i also understand the necessity of
public institutions to provide
access to goods and services to
represent the various publics they
govern
we might say this breaks down at scale
and in the contemporary environment of
the united states it is difficult to be
an
institutionalist on any scale but when
we examine progressive politics in the
u.s and beyond
where struggles of democratic
representation are inching towards
legitimacy
that is happening on the local level
cities are where nearly 60 percent of
the world's population lives
and they are and have always been sites
of contestation
and evolution in ways of living and
governing
they are sites of social protest they
push boundaries of difference and
tolerance
and they are sites of technological
transformation
that have perpetually altered how humans
live together
as georg simel said in the opening lines
of his 1901 essay the metropolis and
mental life
the deepest problems of modern life
derived from the claim of the individual
to preserve the autonomy and
individuality of his existence
in the face of overwhelming social
forces of historical heritage
of external culture and of the technique
of life
the city is the locus of
phenomenological and
corresponding institutional
transformation
simul argues that the metropolis is
where individuality through capitalist
pursuit is placed in tension with the
management of external
stimuli and the throngs of social
difference
i just realized i used the word throngs
twice in this talk that's
that's special he explains a coping
mechanism that he calls the blase
attitude
which enables the city dweller to adapt
to an unprecedented
inundation of stimuli the city is a site
of constant transformation
individuals and groups develop filters
through which to cope
and institutions need to evolve such
that they are capable of governing
within the conditions of rapid change
while simul doesn't use this phrase
this reality implies a certain
intelligence
defined by situational adaptability
it implies a smart city
smart cities it's a designation that has
become a marketing catchphrase that
positions competing municipalities in
the global marketplace of innovation
and creative economies the label tends
to invoke images of responsive
technologies and efficient
infrastructure
there are global smart cities
competitions and mayors around the world
are desperate to put this label on their
place
i don't want to engage in the debate
about the relative value of the smart
city label
the critical arguments in the space are
well rehearsed i do however
want to expand how we think about the
emotional intelligence of cities
mostly as a site of experimentation of
collective pursuit
of new ways of living and governing the
city is an important unit of analysis
because it marks the ability for
institutions to make connections
act in good faith build trust be held
accountable
and cultivate responsibility for
something resembling a public good
smart cities tend to focus on systems
prioritizing certain values of
efficiency and ease
but if we go back to the example of
minneapolis the promise of efficiency
and ease
placed in conflict with the messiness
and complexity of the demands of
emerging publics
led to institutional inaction
which leads me to the overarching
question of this talk
what are the alternative logics of
intelligence that might better
explain and compel democratic urban
transformation
so the shuttering of uh the shuttering
in may
of google's sidewalk labs initiative in
toronto is instructive
the single provider model of a smart
city where google
transformed an industrial area of
toronto's waterfront into a completely
digitized
responsive and smart environment was an
impressive vision of future urbanism
its highly efficient infrastructure near
complete
social connectivity usable interfaces
for information access was a compelling
representation of a smart city
sidewalk labs even held design workshops
to involve members of the surrounding
community to help shape outcomes
but as shannon maderon suggests these
workshops were largely performative
and the well-funded operation overlooked
the relational work necessary to
distribute a sense of ownership and the
process and build trust
with those who had every reason to
believe that their participation would
not
translate into having any real impact
without an opportunity to be heard and
have impact on the outcomes it is not
surprising that within the social
restructuring prompted by the pandemic
this
model of a future smart city would prove
not to be desirable
the logics driving the vision of the
future city were focused on optimizing
for efficiency
around understanding human behavior and
were largely
absent of values that would lead to a
city built on trusting relationships
and systems of caring for people's needs
in march my book meaningful
inefficiencies civic design and an age
of digital expediency was released
this book profiles civic designers or
people within public sector and other
public serving organizations who are
typically working against
dominant organizational cultures to
craft human systems guided by
relationships and care
gabe mugar and i tell stories of people
from small news organizations seeking to
transform the interface between audience
and newsroom
and people from municipal governments
who are desperately de-prioritizing a
focus on streamlining service delivery
by designing inefficiencies into systems
as a means of shifting focus to the time
and labor-intensive work of building
relational trust
with historically marginalized
communities
in february i understood these practices
as fringe as subtle acts of resistance
inside of public organizations but today
the active pursuit of a values-based
transformation has been mainstreamed
the pursuit is in no way straightforward
as we see in minneapolis and toronto it
is expensive
it often runs counter to common sense
practices of incorporating technological
efficiencies
into antiquated organizational practices
and as a result
beyond initial platitudes it is
politically difficult to execute
unlike past waves of public sector
innovation it cannot be addressed by a
small batch of design thinking workshops
or by developing a new app cultural
sensitivity training is not enough
and quotas for increasing diversity fall
short of addressing
structural processes that perpetuate
inequality
what is necessary is not just changing
the appearance of governance
as we are reminded of in boston it is
necessary to
change the logics that guide it
and so i point to meaningful
inefficiencies systems
deliberately designed with slack in
order to hold
space for a diversity of stakeholders
viewpoints
and emerging forms of governance i
compare this logic to that of a
well-designed game
a system with clear goals consistent
feedback
and room to play opportunities for
people to fail
safely experiment with solutions and
build relations within a constrained
environment
meaningfully inefficient programs and
processes not only make engaging
experiences
but when inside these systems one can
build the trust and relationships
necessary for communities and
organizations to thrive
and care for the issues that matter to
them
this is not an argument for more public
meetings the goal is not
simply more dialogue that is part of the
goal but it needs to be situated within
a capture device
that is capable of allowing reflection
learning and growth
we need to be thinking about the systems
of cities that enable them to become
smart to learn to grow to generate to
generate wisdom
so consider the talmud over 6 000 pages
of rabbinical interpretation of the
torah
which has served as the guiding legal
document for rabbinic judaism
the ancient document captures
interpretation born of a cortex
filled with ellipses such that meaning
can be made of the system's logic
in the center is the core text
on the right is rashi's interpretation
and on the left is yet another
interpretation
and then surrounded again by commentary
on the interpretations
this spiral of knowledge capture is a
structural solution to containing
and learning from inefficiencies so what
does this look like on a city level how
can
cities learn they certainly can't be
smart unless they are able to learn
and currently the institutions mediating
public life are not
set up to be smart they contain the
mechanics of public life which might
include voting protesting tweeting
but they lack the ability to contain the
interpretation of these mechanics
the listening the evolution of novel
ideas into agreed upon practices
so i have introduced a logic of
meaningful inefficiencies to use a
different more familiar term
um that is descriptive of institutions
that enable meaningful pl
we can talk about meaningful play um and
importantly we're able to learn from and
evolve from that affective collective
experience so the philosopher bernard
suits explains that
to play a game is to achieve a specific
state of affairs
using only means permitted by rules
where the rules prohibit the use of more
efficient
in favor of less efficient means
and where rules are accepted just
because they make possible
such activity playing a game is the
voluntary attempt
to overcome unnecessary obstacles
so games are by definition then
inefficient
it is in fact the inefficiency of these
systems that cultivate and support the
experience
of play so suit's famous example is uh
is the game of golf where he he
he talks about the most efficient way of
getting the getting the little ball
into the little hole is to pick up the
little ball walk over to the little hole
and drop it in
but instead all these ops these
unnecessary obstacles are placed in the
way
that are that are inefficiencies that
enable that play to happen and we um by
by agreeing to play the game of golf you
are voluntarily entering in
um to a system so that you can play so
that it enables play
and so what what the conclusion here is
that the play is the affective quality
of modern urban life that is necessary
for shared understanding
and collective care reshaping the
mechanisms in which cities are governed
to recognize and develop collective play
is the goal of my research and design
so now i want to talk about two current
studies that are
exploring emerging forms of governance
in cities
the first is an experimental design
project in the city of boston which is
in collaboration with the mayor's office
at new urban mechanics
that explored a collaborative process
for making decisions about new
technologies in the public realm
and the second is an evaluation of an
effort including apoca romania
wherein a loose structure of
multi-sector collaboration
is being formed to advance city-wide
efforts to enhance the well-being of
youth
so i'm going to talk about both of these
projects back to back
so the first one is beta blocks
so beta blocks is a project that
was uh came together in 2018 2019 it was
funded by the knight foundation
and as i mentioned it was in partnership
with the mayor's office of new urban
mechanics and the architecture firm
supernormal
and what we set out to do here was to um
to address the the core problem which
was the way in which technologies
find their way into the public realm so
normally
technologies cameras sensors are
installed in neighborhoods without any
kind of public consultation
around around that technology so there's
the
there's the public sector the government
decision makers there are the technology
companies that tend to make deals with
with one another
and the community for the most part uh
is left out of that decision making as
to what technologies are in their space
and here i'm talking about public realm
technologies sidewalks publicly held
publicly held spaces so
beta blocks essentially was was designed
to invite some friction
in this process and it was a process to
bring
residents and organizers into the
conversation
between government and the technology
companies
now i'm going to explain how we
attempted to do that
there were five primary components to
this
to this intervention uh an exploration
zone which was the site for
experimentation
an advisory group that that had
oversight of that zone
a public exhibit that was uh designed to
encourage dialogue
a specific youth curriculum that was
designed to to
bring youth into the process
specifically and then ultimately
recommendations which was the
collaborative governance
um function of this of this prototype
intervention
so let me go into more detail so in the
city of boston we
uh we identified three um
three neighborhoods where we uh where we
set up exploration
zones there's lower alston chinatown
and codman square
these uh these areas were chosen um
based on a number of factors we looked
at
we looked at need we looked at the data
to determine where there was need
but we also there were also political
factors which was the government
in the case of this particular project
the government uh helping us to decide
where the
um where where friction may be
more or less uh present um and where we
might have more traction within
communities so it was a sort of a it was
a complex process of selection i can
talk more about that later if people are
interested
so the exploration zones were there are
essentially four square blocks
that were uh identified in the city
wherein
um uh wherein um
permitting would be relaxed so that
technologies could be temporarily
installed
within that within that area for the
purpose of public scrutiny
um and as i said the um the each of
these zones was
was governed by an advisory group that
that we set up
um over the course of the project
so um now the advisory groups
were um were
they were created in a number of
different uh a number of different ways
in the different communities they
were designed to include community
leaders volunteers and youth they met
monthly while the zone was in place
the goal was to match local priorities
with with tech
and to identify locations of the tech to
be installed and provide feedback for
those installations and then data
policies and
and then also feedback into business
plans so the part that i didn't mention
is is that the other uh actor
or set of actors here the tech companies
and the
tech companies had their tech that they
would essentially lend to the project
that could be temporarily installed so
they were other stakeholders in this
process
and the community feedback was also part
of the was
the the business plan was open to
feedback which is an important feature
of this program so one of the companies
that we worked with was a company called
sufa
which is a startup out of boston that
actually originated
out of mit and it's essentially a solar
powered
digital billboard that the
great feature of sufa signs is that they
don't need
they don't need an electrical outlet so
they can be placed
in you know you have more variety of
where you can place them
um and they so they could just be
plopped down and then they feature
uh they feature sort of local
advertising they feature municipal data
there's
it's very flexible as to what it is that
that can be featured so sufa
partnered with us and lent us a number
of their
um of their signs and then these were
located by the communities by the
advisory groups
another company that we partnered with
couldn't be more opposite it was
microsoft
and um in in this case we we worked with
microsoft and their
they had developed a new air quality
sensor that we located
um in in that was located in each of the
each of the different zones
one of the things i want to point out
here is that as you see here there's a
sign
um that is next to the air quality
sensor that was
that was uh on the light post that the
air quality sensor was hanging on
that says this is an air quality sensor
this is the one in chinatown as you can
tell
this is an air quality sensor this
device is temporarily installed here to
help understand its value for your
neighborhood and then it includes a
phone number
um and a website um to get feedback and
this was in addition of course to the
um to the official zag or zone advisory
group
so um one of the tasks of the of the
advisory group was to locate the
technologies
so we had the we had
the groups would meet and then determine
the location of the sensors the location
of the signs and and we had other
technologies as well as part of this
pilot
um and so and and these were robust
conversations often because they
involved like
it was a sourcing of problems why would
we need an air quality sensor here we
think we might have
an issue here then we should locate we
should locate the air quality sensor in
this neighborhood or in this corner
um why would we need a digital sign here
let's locate it where there is
particular pedestrian traffic that would
that would actually make use of a sign
so these are the kinds of conversations
that were happening in the zone advisory
groups
so okay i'm going to leave that i'm
going to sort of bracket that so we had
the exploration zones we had the zone
advisory groups
and then we also had a traveling exhibit
and this was designed to
encourage public conversation about
about the issues of technology in the
public realm
one of the features of the traveling
exhibit was this 9 by 18
um inflatable structure that we
we call the beta blob um that
uh that would we could locate throughout
the city and it became a site of
of exploration um of these technologies
so uh in the wherever the beta blob was
located
uh you would first be greeted by by this
rendition
of a of a future and past city um and
and we would ask questions such as um
how do you envision
technology in your city or how do you
use technology in your city and we would
sort of open it up immediately to some
sort of some sort of dialogue
the the as you see here we would put the
the blob
in public spaces so here it is in the in
the rose kennedy greenway in chinatown
park
um we sometimes would call this a hug
object because people would come up to
it and hug it
uh and and it attracted people in that
way it had a
it had a very inviting presence as it as
it turns out
and it became a place to kind of open up
the conversation about about technology
uh one of the most popular features of
this exhibit was this board game
um that uh that you see being played
here uh that that always sort of do
crowds as we had
as we had the blob um up around the city
now again the idea here is we're trying
to create the sort of interface of like
how we can
create um these kinds of conversations
on a public
on a public scale that would actually
lend itself to changing the way that um
that technologies are procured within
uh within the public realm here's
another example in condiment square
um where the the blob became a site of
picnicking
uh as well as playing the game so it was
it it
sort of turned it kind of picked up
multiple functions as it moved about the
city
uh the interesting thing about the blob
is that it was um
it was quite difficult to um to locate
outside
uh as you see because uh it could be
blown away
so we had to we had we had to tether it
down here
to uh to i think with 6 000 pounds of
bricks
um that it had to be tied down to that
had to be sort of moved every time the
the blob would move so it was a
it was a remarkable amount of effort um
to move this
playful object around the city
uh and then it culminated in a um in a
installation in city hall where we
where we had the blob and we and this
was really for policymakers to see the
kind of input that was happening
around the city uh not only the results
of all the
the zone advisory groups but also um uh
but also the the the results of the game
and the game was there
for people to play as well in city hall
it was it was a
place there for over a week i'll just
say a little bit about the youth
curriculum that also operated on the
side
this was a four-part workshop series for
youth 14 to 20.
it focused on data storytelling and
visualization and then the youth at the
end of this created an infographic
driven story
um using quantitative data to sort of
tell
um you know tell these qualitative
stories of how of how people are using
um data and technology in their place
um at the end of the of the zone
advisory groups
there were recommendations that emerged
and this is an example recommendations
that that came from the
specifically about the sufa sign in
chinatown profit sharing with or
financial contribution to the community
oh sorry what conditions need to be met
for super signs to be valuable for
chinatown
profit sharing with or financial
contribution in the community display
relevant information to residents
community events job opportunities
info about local businesses clear and
bilingual labels
and then operate at no financial cost um
to the community
so this is just one example of of a
community response to a particular
tech now i just want to remind you tech
was placed temporarily because permitted
permitting was only temporary
it was there for 60 days and then it was
removed um
and so after that 60 days there was this
opportunity to provide this input
after after this um lengthy process
other things that i won't go into is a
data policy that was also drafted by the
by the zone advisory groups that looked
something like this
where principles that were
collaboratively authored
by the by the group and then these these
were to happen in each of the zones
and so this over time could lead to a
data policy that was emergent
um you know from the from the different
neighborhoods of the city
okay so here are the outcomes um some of
the outcomes
um it was you know years in the making
we developed a valuable model
um that is currently being explored by
by other municipalities
however the prototype was never able to
integrate into governance structures
um and because partly because our
primary
uh partnership was with with the mayor's
office
and we weren't able to fully integrate
into
other other units uh within this city so
what was interesting about this project
is that we focused on the infrastructure
we focus on the logics of the way that
governance happens when it comes to
making decisions about technology and
future of cities
um the result was mixed the result was
um we had the we created an interface
but the
but the um kind of connective tissue
wasn't there
in this in this prototype or not yet i
should say and it's one of the
interesting things about doing work like
this
is that even though we are our design
goal was focused on
um was focused on governance they may
not have been the
those weren't the immediate impacts um
of this project again i can talk more
about this
about this later let me move on to
another project
um and i just want to just i won't i
don't have as much to say about this
this is a new project
a project called our cluj um and i'm
gonna see if
actually i don't think my audio is
connected can you hear that
no okay all right i won't mess with it
um so
the uh our cluj is an initiative that
was
started by a foundation um called the
foundation botner
it's actually a swiss foundation and
they made a commitment
to um to the city of cluj-napoca
for a 10 10 year commitment to it to
um to cluj uh and which is a
sort of an unusual thing um so
the the capital city so collusion is the
capital city of the transylvania region
which is the city has a population of
about 700 000
people it's about the size of boston has
a large concentration of universities
and a vibrant youth sector
and so for the last six months in
collaboration with the romanian-based
research team and also with uh with the
foundation that i mentioned
i've been exploring the structures of
multi-sector collaborative governance
on the city scale and trying to
understand where alternative logics are
being experimented with
and deployed so so far we've interviewed
over 40 people in government
academia civil society and the private
sector twice and i'll explain a bit that
more about that in a second
what we're beginning to see in cluj is a
tension
between local government's concept of
itself
as reformer of a post-communist system
and civil society's concept of itself
as connector but each is paying
significant attention to the complexity
of aligning relationships
and the slow process of building trust
between stakeholders
and the need for better mechanisms with
which to do this
so instead of focusing on individual
tools for transaction
there is increasing attention include to
emerging models of collaboration
which is represented well by one
particular effort that i want to talk
about which is
the urban innovation unit is a
non-governmental r d program aimed at
strengthening collective action and
response to the city's strategic
challenges
this unit sits inside the cluj cultural
center which is a consortium of over 20
organizations in the city
and now the urban innovation unit is
working in parallel with the center of
innovation in civic imagination
which is a newly created unit that
exists within the municipality
so what's fascinating about this example
is that these two organizations
one in government and one without are
working as a mirror image of the other
they have duplicative staff which
enables them to both
operate in a nimble extra governmental
structure while at the same time working
within government
with all the access to direct service
provision that that enables
they are focused on building out new
mechanics of civic participation
ones that would not have been possible
from within government as people still
tend to distrust government especially
on the national level
as such they had the foresight to
develop this unit outside
of government with a plan to transfer it
fully to the municipality in 2022
so what i'm seeing include is a
self-perception of multi-sector work
that is unique
and attention to the mechanisms of
governance in
and out of government with all the
messiness that entails
and a desire to learn from it while it
is far too early to report on any
substantive findings from this research
the novel governance structure is being
built in this secondary city
are well worth paying attention to
so i want to say a bit about methods
here so in order to understand
how people see themselves within these
collaborative structures
and how they might understand the
experience of playing an institutional
context
we're actually using novel research
methods to capture additional insights
so during each of the interviews i have
two to five artists sitting in
to creatively document the process
within two weeks of the interview we
share the completed artwork
with the interviewee and then we have a
follow-up interview to get their
reaction and interpretation of the
creative
representation so the use of art
in qualitative research opens up spaces
of interpretive play
the first interview it's the first
interview i
ask people what they think the second
interview i ask people what they think
about
someone else's representation of them
art
is filled with ellipses and when
incorporated into social scientific
methods
which offers a capture device to learn
from its generative discourse
it can be tumblrtic in design this
method creates productive spaces for
interpretation and self-reflection
that would have otherwise been
impossible people respond to the way
they are represented
the imagery used the emotional
suggestions of the artwork
they see themselves at a distance
creating a space of strangeness
that begs for interpretation
some other art that emerged
from these interviews
this is one of my favorites um
represents a man walking down a dark
a dark hallway and then battling a
bureaucracy monster
that elicits quite remarkable
conversation and i will say actually
i'll just briefly back up to
um to these images um and these are
these are of two different people
and what's interesting about these
images is that they
they create all sorts of dialogue in the
person that
um that that this represented so now
they are able to see themselves
uh they're able to see the way that they
interact with all the pieces of the
puzzle that they've mentioned
and a lot of people um felt again with
the sort of
ambiguity of this of these particular
representations
um became it was incredibly
uh constructive and generative as they
talked about their their
sense of self within this emerging
ecosystem
so let me um
let me come full circle to play now and
conclude
when i talk about my work people
sometimes mischaracterize my interests
as gamification
as i hope i have made clear in this talk
i'm not interested
in gamifying public life gamification
which is the incorporation of game
elements into non-game
systems typically has the effect of
increasing efficiency
motivating one's path to predetermined
goals
i am concerned with games only in so far
as they are model systems to enable
meaningful play
and as such they become a useful
metaphor through which to understand the
transformation of cities
and urban governance so let's return to
the example with which i started this
talk
when we think about the crisis in
minneapolis the question is not how can
we design a game about police violence
and systemic racism
the question is how can our systems of
urban governments accommodate the needs
and
interests of multiple publics by
enabling them to explore
discover and augment the systems that
contain them
this is the key question for smart
cities
and the only way we answer it is by
looking at the logic's
guiding institutions not only the
individual policies
or programs this is my smart city agenda
an agenda i call the civic smart city at
a moment when emerging technologies are
transforming
every aspect of everyday life from how
we live to where we live and how we live
together
research and design interventions need
to be directed at the logics of the
mediating institutions
such that appropriate forms of
governance can emerge
to meet the demands of the governed
thank you very much
thanks eric um so we want to
maybe if we if you uh unsure you're good
um like to invite everyone if you're a
panelist uh just raise your hand and
take your question or use the hand
raising feature under
participant if you're a guest feel free
to ask a question
in the q a uh on the q a
piece um
i know it usually takes people a while
to fire up so i want to start
i'm really intrigued by the um the work
in romania
and i'm wondering um
was there anything particularly
surprising
either in what the artist produced or in
the ways that
the interviewees engaged with uh with
that production
are you are you speaking specifically
about the methods scott
yeah yeah yeah um that's been really
exciting
to do uh it's been um it's been a
learning
learning curve as as we figure out
how best um how best to do it so let me
i'll tell you what was surprising we
have i think
12 different artists that are part of
this group called art of history it's an
artist collective
in cluj um they're they're mostly
students
and um and so what we do is when we when
we have an interview we coordinate
the artists and they and you know we
have two to five as i mentioned
come in and sit in um and uh and
what what's interesting is that all the
artists have different styles right of
course
and so there's nothing particularly
scientific about the approach
uh it's all the artists have different
styles and some of them are much more
representational than others
and some of the artists do kind of you
saw
you saw a couple right you saw the sort
of comic style and then there was
uh you know then the um the other style
that was much more somber
um and and then there's some were even
more representational than that more
like
um you know kind of infographics and
what i found
um perhaps not surprisingly because of
everything based on everything i said
today but what i found
is that the greater the ellipses the
greater the conversation
right so when you clearly say for people
here's an infographic here's what you
just said
and and you do the thing that we do in
social science which is member checking
we say what do you think about the thing
that we think you just said
and then you know they say like good you
know that's good maybe i change that
detail
that's mildly interesting but when you
have
something with a bunch of ambiguity in
it tons of ellipses in the in the
representation then all of a sudden
people
fill those gaps with their
interpretation and then what we get from
that
um is this kind of remarkable
conversation
about their sense of self like so many
many of the people that we interviewed
have talked about
um you saw in in in some of those
uh some of those images of the sort of
um the men that were
you know kind of big and looking over
the city
um people respond to that and what's
interesting
is that people were like i don't see
myself that big in this ecosystem
um i'm uncomfortable with that i'm
uncomfortable being represented that way
why am i looking down you know like
there's all sorts of things about
about the the kind of ambiguity in that
and that
that again gets me to my questions which
is
how does this multi-sector uh
collaboration actually take place
how do people actually work together how
do they see others within their their
collective goals
and how can how are they reimagining
governance um
and we and i can ask them that and
that's again mildly interesting
but when we get it in this sideways way
um
all of a sudden our our um our responses
can be
far more interesting so that's been
really just a delightful
actually in this project have you uh
started to think about a
framework for sort of um evaluating the
responses
um or is it too early for that
yeah it's kind of too early for that
because it's so um it's so emergent like
it's uh even the method i mean again i'm
familiar with with
you know photovoice and other sorts of
other sorts of
methods that one uses to elicit um you
know representation from
people that you are are talking to
um but i this isn't this
i'm not i'm not pulling directly from an
existing method that i know of so if
anybody knows of something that's that's
that's aligned i'd love to hear
about it um and so i am just
i am it is a bit emergent how how we're
going to understand that i mean i'm it's
all interpretive at the moment i mean
we're coding everything so we're going
to be looking for we're still looking
for
um you know we're looking for
aspects of of again collaboration
self-perception
um and and decision-making like those
are the main sort of themes that we're
looking for but
they and they're getting at it in
different ways and we're coding and for
coding for that
cool thank you um so we do now have some
people lined up with questions i think
we'll take the questions from the uh
panelists first in order
and then we'll take the questions from
the q a so um
uh so whoever raised their hand first
should
uh feel free to just unmute and ask the
question
um i see two of you there i didn't see
who was
first
i can bounce first if we just need
someone to go uh hi
i'm all sodder i'm a cms alum
oh and you're muted too muted hi i did i
think
hi i'm maul sutter i'm a cms alum and
currently an assistant professor at the
university of maryland i've also done a
lot of
writing and research on the sidewalk
toronto project and i was
really interested in sort of the idea of
inefficiency
specifically deployed in a political and
policy context because
the one of the major criticisms of the
sidewalk toronto project was that
the procurement process that the rfp had
gone through
to create the opportunity for that
project
was you know according to many critics
myself included
uh wildly corrupt and compromised and
therefore deeply
efficient for sidewalk like it was very
efficient for what they wanted to do and
so i'm i'm interested in approaching the
concept of inefficiency
from perhaps more of a work to rule
perspective
and simply a matter of actually
enforcing existing
policies and so i'm wondering if the
projects that you have going forward
sort of
interface with that at all either
through like responses to corrupt
crew corruptions and existing policies
or merely
adding more more layers to existing
policies to create that inefficiency
uh thanks for the question um it's uh
and and by the way you have a you have a
chapter in in the in my civic media book
so i do
the problem is the policy right the
problem and so the
the the challenge here and the where
where inefficiencies matter is actually
in
in shifting those policies like the
decision-making process in the sidewalk
project was already determined
it shouldn't have been you know we could
have built structures to change the way
that those decisions were made now maybe
maybe it couldn't have been otherwise
because of the nature of the project but
but i guess what i'm what i'm and i'm
curious about your face and i want you
to say
say something back but um but what
like the issue is not so much we have we
have policies the policies are sort of
efficient
you know it's there's an efficient path
towards corruption which is what you
just said
uh and and we're and everyone gets in
line for that right
the challenge is not simply to disrupt
that the challenge is to actually change
the way that
those decisions get made in the first
place which is what we tried to do in
the boston project
in the boston project i mean yeah we had
a lot of sort of like playful elements
to it right but
at the end of the day the goal of that
project was actually to change how
procurement
um get decisions about procurement get
made
it was about changing how value
propositions get oriented and where
smart happens
so all of those things were at the core
of that project
um and so if we get to the point where
the fastest you know the the most
efficient path is corruption then it's
already broken
and so we have to sort of back up and
create some um inefficiencies in that
process to enable that kind of
collective decision making to happen
so now explain explain your face i'll
explain my face which i made on here
um so the the issues that occurred and
this was
eventually brought up before uh the fb
for an ethics committee a parliamentary
ethics committee
um was it included allegations such as
the waterfront uh development authority
had released
details of the cfp2 sidewalk in advance
of releasing them to other
bidders that the cfp was actually
crafted for
sidewalks specifically at the request of
the liberal federal government
like it goes all like it went all the
way down um
in addition to the fact that the
waterfront development authority which
is waterfront toronto
was a well-known corrupt development
authority
in toronto to begin with and had existed
as sort of a very compromised entity for
a long time
um and one of so bianca wiley who is
sort of the major critic from this
perspective
she's the one who knows the most about
procurement policies in toronto and
ontario specifically
um but that her major argument was that
it never adhered to the policies that
were brought forward and like we can
have a
you and i can have a long conversation
about sidewalk toronto because i know
way too much about it at this point
um but so what's interesting to me is
the ways in which
the inefficiencies that might be
implemented
might best look like sort of
traditionally
anarchic or traditionally labor-oriented
slowdown activities
and that type of political resistance so
you know one of the one of the um
distinctions that we make in the book
that i didn't mention
today in the talk is it is the the
difference between a mirror and
efficiency and a meaningful inefficiency
and that's really important right and
and a mirror inefficiency can be
can be bureaucratic slow down it can be
intentional bureaucratic slowdown like
all of those things a meaningful
inefficiency is again one
one design that can cultivate the
you know that can cultivate outcomes
that are that are desirable and not and
not simply anxiety-inducing
so i think what you're what you're
describing again like i i guess i would
come back to you and maybe this is a
conversation for another time but i
would come back to you and say like
um where are like what are the broken
pieces
prior to the prior to the beginning as
you mentioned corruption on the federal
level or the national level
you know corruption um corruption in the
in the development agency
all of those things existed um and and
also a huge desire to partner with
google right that's a that was a
huge win uh for for toronto um so
all those things all those things took
place and again some of these forces are
so large we're not going to be able to
mess with them you know that that
google comes in and it's not like we can
convince cities not to
uh not to take that deal um however
i think that if if the if the
proposition was
was posed differently for example if we
were able to say
no you know a smart city is not a
world's fair style showpiece
but a smart city has to be located
within um within
neighborhoods right like it's got to be
where people live it has to emerge
um from lived experience uh we have to
actually build the capacity to again to
to start from a place not from zero um
to
uh to learn from the um and to learn to
have that capture device that i that i
was talking about if those were the
preconditions
then maybe there would have been
mechanisms to say no google you can't
come in
and that was sort of our desire when we
started beta blocks and i know that's
crazy
but the but the desire in doing this
work is to say like look if we
establish the rules collectively early
on
then we can avoid um some of the
problems that we've seen in the past we
can learn from some of these examples
but
yeah i think there's i'd love to talk to
you more about this i could just make
one point and then i will stop talking
um i think that the
mirror inefficiency versus meaningful
inefficiency is a super great
distinction
and i would actually classify the
long-winded uh co-design process
that google and sidewalk engaged in in
toronto
as a mere inefficiency like it was clear
that nothing
that came out of those meetings was ever
going to have an impact on anything
um versus other types of meaningful
inefficiencies that might have been
implemented
like at the city council level or other
levels
laura thanks
hi eric great presentation um
so my question is more in terms of the
general reception of play or what your
experience has been
in terms of the reception of play as a
concept
and i first was thinking about this when
you showed us the blob
um and then uh also later
you know when you were um showing us the
representations by the artist
and when we were looking at the blob
there uh were predominantly i mean
there are people of all ages but it did
seem to focus much more on children or
maybe young adults
um and i don't know if that's just
because it was this
really big colorful object but i think
that that's part of
kind of what this question is about is
is
um is the idea of play is that
stratified by
age and um does that ever come across
as do people kind of trivialize the idea
of play
and is that ever a roadblock and kind of
how you're
um trying to facilitate these
conversations particularly when you're
presenting the images i think of the
artist uh
to the people you're interviewing
yeah thanks for the question um yes
um i've never had to convince
spend any time trying to convince a
child to play
um so children play
um and and they see a thing that appears
like a play object or even one that
doesn't and
and they will play adults not so much
you know and uh and and so for adults
there is a there is a um
a stage of convincing um because
you know one of the things that play
does is that it it
it levels the playing field right if
um in in play in play conditions
you know there's there's supposed to be
equality
um or at least in game conditions um and
so
what's what's interesting here is that
so i've done i've done a lot of projects
that involve play
that have sort of high level decision
makers and and
and some of these projects that have
happened in you know
in say like in in countries in asia
where there's much more of a sort of
strict hierarchy involved in
um in how these things take place and
what's interesting there is if you have
a boss
with uh with an underling in a situation
where you introduce play
um the boss is usually very unwilling uh
to play
you know because that would that would
suggest a kind of
giving over to the possibility that they
may not be on a higher level
than the other people that they're
playing with so and i think the same is
true for generation you know it
certainly plays out generationally so
back to
beta blocks um there's a lot of things
that we learned
in putting that blob out
one is that kids are attracted to it
would come over to it and and the other
is that adults were suspicious of it
because they thought
someone was going to sell them something
right so so it was
so people would sort of you know very um
they would be trepidatious they would
walk they would kind of look a sconce
like that's interesting
i'm going to keep walking not going to
go over there and then we learned
quickly actually
because at one point we were out there
and we stupidly
um i had um you know me and my team were
out there with a with a
clipboard you know it's like what were
we thinking like we were standing in
front of it like with the clipboard to
take notes and like of course people saw
us and ran the other way
um so we got rid of the clipboard um
and then the other thing that we learned
is that the um
the the blob was very programmed so
there are actually
stations around the blob we had designed
it for like
activities in each of the stations and
we thought that was the way to go
um and and again people would look over
and they would see that there was a
thing and they would be a little bit
unsure about how to engage in it
um but then one time we were actually at
fish pier in boston
um blob was there during a strangely it
was during a
fish festival not fish the band but fish
the the creatures
uh and uh and so there is lots of lots
of fish and
and uh and food and then there was there
was our blob
and uh and people come over and talk
about technology with us
um but the most use it got was when we
had cleaned up our stuff and we had like
moved all the tech out of the way and we
had
like we moved it into the van and the
blob was still there
and then it was an unattended blob and
the people were climbing on it and
jumping on it and like
jumping through it and it was like all
of a sudden it had a completely
different um
use value right and and became a pure
play object
and then people weren't afraid to move
up to even adults weren't afraid to go
up to it
and so i think that was something that
we learned about you know again play is
something that
um you know children are willing players
adults you have to convince
but when you're introducing play into a
into a space where it's unfamiliar
um then you really have to design for
for that
um for that uncertain the the kind of
uncertainty that that comes with
um you know entering into an unsafe
space so um so that's been that's been
incredibly uh intriguing um
other times i've experienced this this
thing um this this
concept of sort of generational divides
is that
um you know making creating conditions
for
for for um youth to work with
adults right when adults feel like
they're um that they'll they're willing
to play as long as
they're enabling a child to play but if
they have to be the primary player
they're less comfortable with that so
they'll step away from the play
experience so that's so that kind of
intergenerational connection has been
a really important learning experience
through through some of my design work
thank you um we have a number of
thoughtful questions in the qa
and i could read them out loud but i
thought there eric can you open the qra
easily is that
in front of you because if it's not a
problem it might be better for you to
quickly look at them and answer them
directly
i was going to say it might be helpful
to read just because the uh
future viewers of the recording oh okay
sure then i'll be happy to read i just
didn't want to sort of like yeah yeah
um so the first question is how does the
move to a civic smart city and the forms
of data and information
flow around public policy and decision
making
sit with parallel developments in media
architecture by urban design firms
parens the physical structure of cities
are these comfortable alliances
hmm
parallel developments in media
architecture by urban design firms
i mean i guess i don't i have to
understand the
the example a bit more i mean certainly
now look i mean
i'm i want to as much as possible
use play here as a um
as a generative constructive space right
like that's
that's how i'm understanding play now
often you know play is used as
as um uh it's used as aesthetic
you know so we i can imagine sort of the
the design of
sort of um uh you know kind of silicon
valley
uh office office spaces right the sort
of play aesthetic
that gets used uh as a as a sort of a
theater of fun um that's not
that's not at all what what i what i'm
interested in and i think and
and i don't know eric if if this is what
you're referring to but i think that
there is
there's certainly in the in the
architecture in the uh media design or
the urban design space
play is an aesthetic and i think that
that differs from the the kind of
institutional um in the kind of
institutional logics that i'm
i'm trying to direct our attention to so
i wouldn't i so i guess to answer your
question
i think that is an uncomfortable
alliance um
and and i and i think i would sort of
point to one being
an aestheticization of play and perhaps
another one not and maybe this would be
a better conversation if i had
if we had an example and maybe you can
put one in the in the chat eric
um to talk about but we can move on to
another question and come back to that
so um barbara bulk asks what
what would what would it take to create
connective tissue in boston
for beta blocks to achieve lasting
transformation
that's a that's a tough question um
barbara that
that is um you know it's funny it's
with uh with these with projects like
this right that are that are
prototypical in nature
um where you know i think what it would
have taken is a is
a different approach from the very
beginning um and
uh my colleague who i think is is here
um
listening and john harlow um uh
will you know he we worked on the
project together and one of the
frustrations from the beginning was our
was was the lack of ability to sort of
connect to other
um to other offices within within the
city
and um and so understanding
the the the procedure of institutioning
um is something that needed to happen
earlier on and i think what's
interesting is that
now that this project is completed in
boston i actually have more faith that
it'd be picked up by other cities
because it becomes kind of
representational um in a in
in perhaps a productive way so you know
in
the city of miami is interested in in
this um because it be
because it's a blueprint for them and
they can say okay here's how let's let's
start again let's use this blueprint and
see where we can go with this
um whereas i feel like in the city of
boston it might be harder to do that
um at this point so so that's my that's
my sense of that and it's also it's
interesting again if you've if you've
done projects like this before sometimes
sometimes they function like conceptual
art pieces right sometimes they
sometimes at the end the the
documentation of the project and the
and hopefully the relationships built
and the good faith built
um become a a kind of conceptual model
um that that that sort of energizes
discourse
right and um and i feel like at this
point
and i i don't want that of any project
that i i don't set out to do conceptual
art
um and but i also know that sometimes
that's what happens
and especially within within you know
university environments
you know we're good at that we're good
we're good at turning things into
conceptual art maybe
we're better at that than we are the
other and i'm more interested in in the
other i'm more interested in the
you know finding paths to persistence
and institutional transformation
which is the goal of the work but i'm
also becoming more comfortable with
sometimes we'll pull out of it with some
um with some conceptual art that can
have an impact um
beyond the original location of the of
the prototype
so that's so i think it's a complicated
question but
that's that's as best as i can i can do
at this point
um thank you uh for that question we
we have from nicole west bastoff um
she's a phd student in public policy and
sds at harvard and works on smart cities
and she says i often find myself asking
questions about what it
what makes it possible to say no to
public-private partnerships
or technology installations versus what
it means to bring people to the table to
participate in decision-making
around planning and implementation an
example is
this contrast was made plainly evident
in the sidewalks labs case as well as
for example amazon hq2 in new york
how do you see the role of play in
putting no on the table
versus in widening participation or just
slowing things down
oh god good question um so again i think
this goes back to maul's question about
about um uh about the
the political power that's involved when
when
when a google or amazon comes to the
table you know getting to know
it seems impossible um however
however um i do have faith again and
this is why i'm i'm
i'm you know i'm a municipalist i'm
interested in cities i think cities have
there's there's a lot to gain um from
from learning from cities
um i do think that there is possibility
for um you know for cultivating
decision-making processes first so
i'll point to i'll put to one example in
boston actually which was the olympics
um you know when the when the olympics
was was coming to boston there was a
there was a pretty significant
anti-olympic
um uh movement here uh in the city that
did say no to the olympics now that's
different than saying no
to google because one is a more direct
transfer of cash
um than than the olympics but it was
certainly it was it was but it was
definitely a sort of
um revenue stream that was rejected so i
think it's possible
and that's one that's that's one
possible case but what i guess what i'm
saying is that if we had
a clearer foundation of
ways in which municipalities can
effectively partner
with communities and neighborhoods and
groups
if we had that worked out now again i go
back to what
what both andrea campbell and julia
mejia have
have said um in their in their own
governing which is
um which is you know how do we how do we
create a city government um that not
only
looks like the people that it's
governing
but actually has a different value
structure from which to govern
right that's really what this is after
and can we do that
by um by building the mechanics of
governance
uh in a way um that that is
that is more participatory that is more
collaborative now this
is hap this happens through mechanics
and so this is what we're doing in my
um in my class is that we're thinking
about these sort of mechanical elements
of
of co-creation and in government um
and sometimes it feels really small
right like we're looking at a we're
looking at a particular place in which
we can intervene
in um in the process of decision making
but this is all about building models
for to change that logic right so um
again if the model typically
in the way that the way that cities say
no is through protest
where there are decision makers then
there's a then there's a protest there's
something that rises to the attention
um because of masses of people taking to
the streets and then and then officials
are pushed into
um you know changing their decision
right like that's often how governance
works
um is that that there's like here we're
going to do we're going to make a
decision
and then uprising and then okay we're
going to make a different decision
that's not
very effective right um now it's it
it works temporarily but as we saw in
minneapolis um
it doesn't doesn't create models for
actually persistent change what it does
is that it that there's a lot of lip
service paid to the
to the acknowledgement of the value
transformation but we don't have the
structures in order to make decisions
differently
we don't have the structures to make
decisions differently about
policing let's say either in minneapolis
or in boston and so
again in the city the city of boston is
also attempting to
uh reform um its policing structure and
we can do that through policy changes so
we can make different rules
and we can and we can make different
policies but until we change the way
that policies get made
we're still gonna we're gonna find
ourselves in this in the in the same old
spiral um so so a really good question
i have to believe that there is a path
to know
um but i think that that's that's a long
haul
um and that's that's a that's a a
really sort of focusing in on governance
structures and changing the way that
happens across
cities in the united states and then
also learning from um
cities around the world like barcelona
is a is a leader in this
we have a question from hamid reza
nassiri um
thanks for the great talk i'm curious
how you think allende's project
cyber city in chile connects to such
multisective
sector collaborative efforts in
governance one does that project even
come up in the conversation in psychical
design settings
and two what do you think about how that
groundbreaking but unfortunately
unfinished project can inform these more
recent efforts
what a good question and no it doesn't
come up um
it doesn't come up as often as it as it
should
um you know i
i don't even know how to respond to that
question um
because the quote that ultimately what
you're asking
is how can we
how can we learn from that project and
maybe the answer to that to your
to your question is similar to my
conceptual art answer
right is that is that we we we learn
from these things by
through um through storytelling right
this is the this is the
sort of generative discourse of these
projects and all too often these
projects will
these projects will presumably fail and
then they'll get talked about as a
failure right so here's another here's
another problem like you have a project
that
that that happens it fails to do a thing
um and and two things can happen
it gets buried because it has failed to
do that thing
or the people who are doing the project
can't talk about
failure because they want to continue
getting funding or they want to continue
getting support or
or do more business so there's just no
room to talk about failure
so we never get to talk about why things
don't work
we only get to talk about why things
work um and so we don't learn
from things so you know so the project
in chile is a great example of
of a project that um that
failed in certain respects to meet some
goals but not in others and it doesn't
get talked about en
enough because we often don't make the
room to talk about projects that
um that can function like conceptual art
that have that have worked in other ways
that have created relationships
dialogues networks
that have done all the kind of um the
sort of
soft aspects i guess if you want to call
it that of um
of this work but we don't have the sort
of business language to talk about it
in most settings so it's another reason
why i think that
um you know that sort of if if
universities can
find a way to sort of move the critical
discourse out into other spaces and make
room for failure i think that's another
wonderful um function for universities
in this public discourse
um thanks for thank you for that i think
the one last thing um unless
people still they'd like to raise their
hand there's still another moment or two
but
eric did expand on his question um
the first question my question is a bit
about trying to
think of cities as built spaces that
have to be undone to develop
relationships with their constituents
i'm going to think of cities as built
spaces that have to be undone to develop
relationships with their constituents
yeah so
it's not a question that you have to
answer thank you for saving me eric i
mean it's an interesting question uh
because uh it's it's true i mean it's
one of the problems with
um with the way that cities get built
it's because
um it's expensive and
and they get built and there's
hesitation to unbuild uh
things uh that that are built um
and so i think that that's uh you know
it's it is an issue and this is why i
think there's lots of opportunity in
thinking about media spaces
uh or thinking about sort of soft
urbanism um where
uh where we can where there are
possibilities for
transformation that don't include um
bricks and mortar or breaking
you know breaking ground um so that's
another way to think about cities and
and again
like um beyond the built environment uh
i think we have to think about cities
institutionally as well which is another
which is another thing that doesn't
necessarily require the raising of
buildings
um to transform institutions it might i
mean some some
buildings need to be raised to transform
institutions but i think that mostly
uh they don't
tomah you have a question oh i think i'm
butter i
wanted to ask you question first oh
i think you're the i think you're the
only one that's true okay
well one person then the other one uh so
i was
thank you eric uh i
i assume that different communities have
different needs
and when you like do these like
workshops in different
areas i'm wondering how
the government can fulfill like
different needs in the communities or
which
like how can they decide like which
uh things can like
uh function for
for like like different communities
let's say how can governments decide
what can function for different
communities like if like
when you create like these different
workshops i assume
that different communities have a
different needs or
like prefer certain certain texts but
like i guess
government doesn't have uh enough
funding
to like you know fulfill different needs
so i'm wondering
uh how could they decide
which ones are the one that they will
pursue
yeah i mean i think the answer is that
they shouldn't be deciding on their own
uh which which one to pursue and this is
another reason why
the why it's so important to find
mechanisms of collaborative governance
right that that
um that when governments are left to
make a decision
alone um about where the need
is uh within within any kind of um
any kind of place those decisions tend
to be bad
um so when there's opportunities for
collaboration
then the it is about sort of
um daylighting some of the concerns that
government um
often conveniently ignores
um and that you know again sort of
brings that to the table so i'll bring
i'll bring it back to cluj
so include um you know the the
the most marginalized populations
includes are the roma uh
and and and hungarians um and
and you know and they and they have
largely been systematically excluded
um from from governance of all sorts
uh and in fact the the sort of bias
against them
is somewhat accepted right and so it's
so you know in some ways it's it's it's
different than
than the discourse in the united states
where um
you know again at least at least in
appearance um
those those biases are not publicly
acknowledged most of the time
um and so there in that case
in that case what that requires is that
it requires the resources
and the effort to bring people to the
table that have been systematically
excluded from that table
um that it requires will from from um
it requires political will from from
government bodies but once but
but more so than that it requires the
mechanisms
to accomplish that so for example in
incluge
um you know the mayor is is
um invested in building um you know in
build
in building uh integrated housing for
roma populations which was pretty
radical uh for romania and um and you
know and so like that
that that example is a really sort of
interesting one and now coming from the
mayor it's one thing
it's actually building that's not
necessarily going to get done
what's going to get it done is actually
putting in the resources to bring
to bring those impacted communities to
the table and that's what's beginning to
happen there and that's what takes time
and that's what you know requires that
sort of um you know that level of trust
where you know if you've been asked to
come to the table over and over again
and every time you come to the table
your finger gets cut off you're not
going to come to the table anymore
um you know so so if you have a new if
you have new leadership then you have to
slowly
build that trust with people to say that
yep we're inviting you to come to the
table and we're actually going to feed
you this time you know like it's a
completely different relationship that
is that is being built so i think
it is a it is political will its
commitment to develop
to commit resources um and then
ultimately it's about
it's about the sort of long-term trust
building that's required
amber sorry i hadn't seen your hand okay
thomas if you you're it's your turn now
thank you um so i'm wondering if we
think of collaboration
as the way for institutional change i
wonder if we should rethink also account
delegation and accountability too
yes we should tomas uh we should rethink
uh so now again accountability is an
interesting uh
is an interesting question uh
accountability tends to suggest
a personal accountability right that one
is one is accountable for for
their actions and in that sense i think
that there's you know really interesting
literature that looks to sort of
transform transferring accountability to
responsibility
um responsibility tends to be more
implies a kind of
reciprocity right that you're that we're
responsible
um that when we're responsible to
something or to someone
that's that's different than being
accountable for our own actions
and i think you know that that that
governance needs to be able to like yes
we need to rethink governance
but we also need to shift accountability
to responsibility
it's not about government government
being responsible to the governed
um and it's not about the governed being
responsible to the government but it's
about a mutual responsibility
that is that is absolutely necessary and
again a mutual responsibility to one
another
um and this is this is tied to you know
the
the other thing that i didn't really get
a chance to talk much about is
is the frame of a care ethic right that
that you know if we if we start to sort
of shift
um you know we we if we move
some of this language to um you know
away from say
uh impact and more towards care right
then we're realigning priorities by
assigning a different kind of value
uh to the work that's happening in
cities and if we think about
um if we think about what happens in
cities
as a kind of mutual network of care um
and we're seeing some of that bubble up
because of the pandemic right whereas
care is kind of rising to the surface
it's something that people are actually
talking about in cities
um and so the the can we transfer some
of those
some of those bubbling up actions to the
values that are that are going to be
guiding the systemic change of these
institutions and i do hope like that's
that we can start moving a lot of that
language into a into a different space
there's a book that i haven't i only
read the first couple pages of but it's
the care manifesto
just came out i don't know if anybody's
seen that yet but uh
um it promises to be um to be fantastic
i'm gonna recommend it before reading it
so there you go thank you
thanks for the question thanks i think
we
um obviously we're coming near the end
of time but we do have one more question
in the qa so i thought i'd
for those who can stick around from the
perspective of municipal government
how should they measure the
effectiveness or performance or
otherwise evaluate
the products of meaningfully inefficient
projects
and is there a risk of missing the point
yeah in doing that yeah what a great
question
um yes indeed and this this is
um this is how like in a in a in a
culture of evaluation
um and you know and a need for for
measuring impact yes we have to change
the conversation about about this
um i'll bring up um
we i i developed uh with um with
colleagues a a tool called meter which
is m-e-e-t-r
um and it's m-e-e-t-r i put it in the
chat here
um actually here's
um so uh so that
so i developed a tool called meter which
is specifically
about evaluating different kinds of
questions um
and and so in in what meter does is that
it looks to it looks
to create a kind of reflective
evaluation process
for practitioners so that they can
understand um along two primary axes
that they
they can understand their work along
social infrastructure
uh building strong social infrastructure
and longevity
um and so and and we do that by by
breaking down four activities and these
are described in the meaningful and
efficiencies book but four activities
including network building holding space
um distributed ownership and persistent
input is what we call them
um and these activities are as we
describe them these are the
this is the work that people are
actually doing in order to accomplish
uh the kind of goals that i'm describing
and so
the challenge is we're not going to get
anywhere if we continue to measure
the same things that we've long been
measuring um that we have to start
measuring different things and sometimes
that
what those things are are these um
mostly invisible practices that people
are engaging in in order to
to transform their their organizations
or their places
um and so yeah so so i'm very interested
in this problem
um and like i said we've developed this
tool this is being used
um this is being used by um by
journalists
journalism organizations uh it's being
used by
um by folks in cities i'm actually we're
all
using it for my some my active research
projects in fact include we're having
the
um the practitioners that we're working
with use the meter tool
to self-evaluate their own practice so
that we can begin to get at a different
kind of metric
um for um you know for understanding the
value of this work
so i think along with sort of changing
the language that
that you know tomas was talking about um
in order to change the language we
actually have to change the criteria
um by which we evaluate these things
um and so that's it has to be a parallel
practice
so i appreciate the question
well thanks everybody for coming um
obviously eric i thought this was great
um and
clearly there was a lot there was lots
of interest in what you had to say so um
really glad you were able to do this and
thank everyone again for coming this
week
um look forward to seeing everybody next
week same time
thanks very much everyone bye-bye bye